thank thank you to him for that
introduction there is a letter to the
editor on the way to the New York Times
she gave me some hostages to fortune I
only have one lesson for today from
Lincoln but it's a very important one
and that's that we should pay as much
attention and a serious attention to the
founding fathers as he did Abraham
Lincoln was absorbed with them
throughout his life the most famous
expression obviously is in the
Gettysburg Address where he says our
fathers set forth on this continent a
new nation conceived in Liberty that was
November 1863 but three years before
that February 1860 and the Cooper Union
address his first important speech
outside of Illinois the kickoff of his
first presidential campaign he said of
slavery as our fathers marked up so let
it be again marked as a as an evil to be
restricted let us speak as they spoke on
it and let us act as they acted on it
and six years before that October 1854
in a speech in Peoria Illinois one of
the longest he ever gave three our
speech laid out the themes that would
guide him for the rest of his career he
said our Republican robe is soiled and
trailed in the dust let us turn and wash
it white in the spirit of the revolution
now this afternoon I want to look at the
three founding fathers who were most
important to him he encountered them at
different periods of his life
drew different things from them George
Washington
Thomas Paine Thomas Jefferson I also
want to talk about his actual father
Thomas Lincoln because I think some of
the yearning that Lincoln brought to his
study the founding fathers came from his
disappointment with his actual wand and
I'll talk about one last father who was
especially important as the Civil War
dragged down God the Father now Thomas
Lincoln was born in Virginia he married
in Kentucky began his family there
Abraham was born in 1809 in 1816 Thomas
moved his family to Indiana which was
then a brand-new state and then in 1830
he moved to Illinois where he lived for
the rest of his life there was a fashion
among historians in the 20th century of
depicting Thomas Lincoln as an heir do
well almost a bomb scholars have
rejected that they've moved on Thomas
Lincoln was a subsistence farmer and a
carpenter all his life but he never left
bad debts he served on several juries
which was a sign of respectability if
not of wealth he was also a trustee of a
frontier Baptist Church in Indiana that
the Lincoln's belonged to he sent his
daughter Sarah and his son Abraham to
one house schools so that they could
learn to read write and do simple
mathematics
these were skills that he thought they
should have but Thomas and his son never
got along they never saw eye to eye part
of that was a matter of labor as soon as
Abraham reached his full growth his
father hired him out to neighbors who
needed fields cleared or rail split and
all the wages that Abraham
and his father pocketed now this was a
common practice in those days but common
practices can strike different people
different ways and Abraham hated it
resented it deeply a second difference
between the two of them was that
although Thomas wanted his children to
learn to read and write
he didn't understand reading as an
experience that would broaden and deepen
you he thought of it as a skill but his
son Abraham thought it was a portal to
different worlds a portal to
understanding his own world and his own
thoughts
his stepmother Sarah Lincoln who
survived Abraham was interviewed as an
old lady she described how her stepson
if he didn't understand something that
adults were talking about he would ask
later what did it mean then he would
write it down then he would rewrite it
in his own words until he was satisfied
that he understood this when he didn't
have paper he'd write it on a board with
charcoal and when he covered the board
he'd plane it off and write it again and
that's the kind of reaction that he had
to reading and writing and this was
beyond his father's can when Lincoln
wrote a campaign autobiography in 1860
when he's running for president he said
of his father that he never learned more
than bungling Lee to write his own name
and I thought there's there's so much
feeling in that word bungling Lee he
could have said he never learned more
than to write his own name but he had to
say bungling Lee and I think that meant
I learned to do more you didn't because
you didn't want to so there was this
gulf between the two men still there
were three things that Abraham got from
his father although he never
acknowledged them one was strength
physical strength
Thomas and Abraham were differently
built Thomas was 510 and stocky Abraham
of course we're familiar with his
ganglion figure 6-4 but they were both
strong powerful man in an early 19th
century America this was important
because when you moved into a new
community there was communal hazing you
had to prove yourself to the local tough
guy in wrestling or some other form of
contest and both Thomas and Abraham had
those experiences and they passed them
the second resemblance between father
and son was that they were both
temperate they didn't drink alcohol an
early 19th century America this was very
rare Gordon would in his book Republic
of Liberty which covers the early
American Republic he gives statistics
about annual consumption of hard liquor
and they're simply astonishing this was
a nation of alcoholics and and of course
what they were drinking was the worst
possible stuff I mean from distilled
stuff from local stills but neither of
the Lincoln's did it a third quality of
Thomas's that his son picked up was that
Thomas was a great storyteller and we
know this from two cousins of the
Lincoln family on Abraham's mother's
side two brothers named Hanks and both
of them lived with the Lincoln's for a
number of years and one of them said
that Thomas Lincoln was as good a
storyteller as Abraham and the other one
said he was even better and we know that
Lincoln was a great teller of stories he
used it throughout his life to entertain
people to distract them to keep them at
a distance and this was a quality that
he got at home from Thomas Thomas
Lincoln as I said was a farmer all his
life he dies in 1851
Abraham named a horse after him old Tom
and one of his sons when he's going to
Washington to be inaugurated for the
first time in 1861 he visited his
father's grave he saw that there was no
stone upon it he said I'll have to I'll
have to have one put there but he never
did so that was the end of their
relationship if we don't get what we
want from our families and no one ever
gets everything he wants from his family
we look for it elsewhere we look for
surrogates and substitutes and in early
America the handiest substitutes were
the founding fathers the generation of
men who'd won the Revolutionary War and
who'd written the Constitution the last
of them died off in the 1830s but they
were ubiquitous their reputations were
everywhere Lincoln never never met any
of them although their lives overlapped
Thomas Jefferson retires from the White
House just a few weeks before Abraham is
born but young Abraham never got to the
East Coast where the founding fathers
lived none of them ever came out to what
was on the frontier where he lived so
the only way he could encounter them was
in books one of the most important books
which he read as a boy was a very
popular one it was by Mason Locke Wiens
parson Weems called the life of George
Washington and this was the first
biography of Washington that was
published and it's still in print today
Weems is one of those writers like James
Fenimore Cooper or HP Lovecraft his
sentences aren't very good but his
stories are terrific and the proof is
that we know them there in the national
mind the most famous story of course is
the story of George and the cherry tree
that when George Washington is a little
boy his father
in the hatchet and when he's swinging it
around he accidentally barks a prized
cherry tree when mr. Washington sees
what's happened he asks his son
how did this happen do you know who did
this and George says I cannot tell a
live paw you know I can't tell a lie I
did it whereupon his father praises him
for his honesty but that's not what
impressed Lincoln in parson Weems he was
not impressed with Washington as a good
boy he was impressed with Weems of
stories of Washington as a great man and
we know this because Lincoln said so
himself
in 1861 when he was on his way to his
first inauguration he left Springfield
early in February he took a train
through the Midwest and through part of
the Northeast on his way to Washington
he was showing the flag as the country
was splitting apart and on February 21st
he came through a Trenton New Jersey and
he gave a speech to the legislature and
he told the New Jersey State Senate he
recalled Weems his life of Washington he
said he had that book as a little boy
and what most struck him in it was Weems
his account of the Battle of Trenton and
he mentioned the crossing of the
Delaware the hardships suffered by the
soldiers and the struggle with the
Hessians and you adieu you would think
and some modern biographers have said
this was a very obvious thing for
Lincoln to say it's the day before
Washington's Birthday he's in Trenton
New Jersey
why not refer to Weems in the Battle of
Trenton but the most important thing
that Lincoln has to say about the battle
is what we mented as the most important
he said boy though I was I thought that
there must have been something important
that those men
struggled for even more important than a
war for independence but something of
value to all men and all times and what
Lincoln thought that was was liberty and
if you read Weems his account of the
Battle of Trenton that's exactly what
Wayne
because after he gets Washington and his
troops across the Delaware they have to
march a few miles on to the city of
Trenton and as they're marching Weems
introduces an allegorical figure
hovering over them it's a woman the
spirit of Liberty
Weems says that she has been driven out
of Europe she's come to the woods of
America as her last refuge but her
enemies have followed her with soldiers
and armies who will defend her only this
little band of men and before the
Americans charge the Hessians Weems has
Washington say to his troops all I ask
you to remember is what you are about to
fight for Weems presents the Battle of
Trenton as a struggle for liberty in the
world and that's what Lincoln saw it as
and what he sees his own presidency as
being and he connects the two in this
speech and Trenton the second founding
father that made a deep impression on
Lincoln came to him in his 20s and this
was Thomas Paine
now Thomas Paine was was one of the
greatest journalists who ever lived
his patriotic essay the American crisis
written before the Battle of Trenton
opens with the immortal paragraph these
are the times that try men's souls his
pamphlet common sense sold a hundred
fifty thousand copies in January 1776 in
a country of three million the
equivalent today would be fifteen
million that's that's a very good sale
but in the 1780s Paine wrote another
book which almost destroyed his
reputation
in the United States that was the age of
reason the age of reason was a furious
assault on organized religion pain was
not an atheist he said I believe in one
God and no more but he thought that all
organized religions were system set up
to terrify and enslave mankind and so in
the age of reason he makes some cracks
at Islam he makes more Judaism but most
of his criticism is directed at
Christianity which was the religion he'd
been brought up in and the religion of
most of his readers and pain gives an
account of when he says he first began
to doubt he says he was seven or eight
years old and someone in his family gave
a reading at home of a sermon on the
substitutionary atonement this is the
doctrine that Christ died for our sins
and that his death pays the debt that we
owe for having sinned Payne says he left
left the house walked out into the
garden and he remembers I revolted at
the recollection of what I had heard and
I thought to myself that it was making
god almighty act like a passionate man
that killed his son when he could not
revenge himself any other way and as I
was sure a man would be hanged that did
such a thing I could not see for what
purpose they preached such sermons now
the substitutionary atonement as has
been explained for centuries by by
Christian theologians but pain was
taking a very literal take on this and
on all other Christian doctrines and
it's very biblically based he goes
through the Bible looking for
contradictions and apparent
contradictions he's kind of the ideal
adversary for a nation of Bible readers
which is what America was and the age of
reason did circulate in America
including rural America and Lincoln in
countered pain when he was in his
twenties in Illinois in fact Lincoln was
so impressed with pain that he wrote a
pamphlet of his own making similar
arguments he was going to show that
Jesus was an ordinary illegitimate son
and that no one needed to read the Bible
he was telling his young friends about
this one night they were they were
gathered around the stove and a in an
older man store and this older man whose
name was Hill asked to see lincoln's
pamphlet and he put it in the stove the
reason he did that is that young lincoln
was already interested in politics and
mr. hill knew that you won't go far in
illinois in the 1830s if you write a
pamphlet explaining that jesus was an
illegitimate child so Lincoln learned to
be circumspect about his early religious
skepticism now over the years his
religious opinions changed but I think
there was one thing he took from pain
that never changed for him it was
permanently useful and that was how to
make serious arguments using humor pain
is very good at this whether you agree
with him or not he is very good at
making his points with jokes one one
such he's talking about the virgin birth
and he asks if any girl today
were to say that she got pregnant by a
ghost and that an angel told her so
would she be believed even if she swore
to it now again the virgin birth has a
lot of theology that underlies it and
that explains it but this is a very
literal way to talk about it it's
talking about the girl an angel a ghost
and it adds a humorous twist so so
that's Payne's way of making a serious
aggressive point and Lincoln himself
would do this over and over again
in the 1850s and 60s when when Democrats
would II would charge him and other
Republicans with being with being race
mixers this was a very common Democratic
charge
why else would Republicans be opposed to
the restriction to the expansion of
slavery or to slavery well they must
want to sleep with black women and there
were many cartoons on this theme of
supposed Republican celebrations were
all the men are dancing with black
ladies and low-cut dresses it's a very
common Democratic cartoon and Lincoln
would respond to such charges by saying
just because I don't want a black woman
for slave doesn't mean I have to have
her for a wife I can just leave her
alone and again he's taking an abstract
issue and he's making it very concrete
he's saying here's me here's this black
woman I don't have to go to bed with her
but he's also saying I can leave her
alone which means she can be free so
within the joke there is a serious point
a Lincoln did not have to go to Thomas
Paine to learn to be funny he already
knew that as a storyteller from his
father but pain shows him how to use
humor to make serious points the third
founder that has a powerful impact on
Lincoln is Thomas Jefferson and Lincoln
starts calling on Jefferson in 1854 at
the time of his Peoria speech and
continues to do so for the rest of his
life Jefferson had a very long political
life he's a complicated man and Lincoln
was aware of that but the Jefferson that
he admires is the young Jefferson the 33
year old man who wrote the Declaration
of Independence and wrote in there and
made that an American official position
that all men are created equal
18:59 Lincoln was invited to a
celebration of Jefferson's birthday in
Boston he couldn't go but he sent them a
message that he clearly worked over and
hoped that it would be reprinted in
Republican newspapers and it was he said
all honor to Jefferson who had the
wisdom and the forecast to insert into a
merely revolutionary document a
principle that would be valid for all
times and for all ages and he also said
that Jefferson set forth the definitions
and the axioms of a free society and
this is the Thomas Jefferson that
Lincoln quoted and referred to his most
famous reference again is the beginning
of the Gettysburg Address because four
score and seven years ago four score and
seven from 1863 goes back to 1776 and
the year of the Declaration of
Independence and that was what Lincoln
points to as the start of America's
independent history the Gettysburg
Address was given at the dedication of
the cemetery and there was a lot of
death in Abraham Lincoln's life his
mother died when he was nine his sister
Sarah died when he was 20 he lost a
sweetheart and Rutledge in his early 20s
and he had one of his four sons died in
the 1850s and other died when he was in
the White House Lincoln only served in
one war it was an Indian War in northern
Illinois called the Black Hawk War he
didn't see any action but he did see men
had been scalped and he remembered that
on the top of every head there was a
spot the size of a silver dollar and he
said that blood seemed to be everywhere
that was a very common experience of
death in America in the 19th century
there was high mortality from disease
and there were Indian Wars in addition
to the larger wars that we fought but
the Civil War was an uncommon experience
of death it was not something that
Lincoln had ever seen before never seen
anything like it or contemplated it and
the war touched people that he knew one
of the first battles in Northern
Virginia the Union took the city of
Alexandria and one of Lincoln's law
students Elmer Ellsworth led a charge of
Union man into a hotel that was flying a
rebel flag he'd tore it down and then he
was shot to death by the owner with a
shotgun who was himself killed by
Ellsworth second command at the end of
1861 and December
Edward Baker another friend Lincoln's
was killed at the Battle of balls Bluff
a baker had been a friend of his in
Illinois politics Lincoln had named a
son after Edward Baker Baker was the man
who introduced him to the crowd at his
first inauguration by then Baker was a
senator from Oregon so he's killed in
December 1861 the someone at the funeral
said that Lincoln wept like a child
William McCulloch was a court clerk from
the Judicial Circuit that Lincoln
traveled in Illinois and at the
beginning of the war he asked the
president-elect for help getting into an
Illinois Cavalry Regiment the reason
McCullough needed Lincoln's help is that
he only had one arm he was a fifty year
old man who'd lost an arm in a farming
accident but he wanted to fight for his
country and for Liberty so Lincoln got
him in the cavalry regiment he became a
lieutenant colonel Don a colonel and he
was killed in December 1862 in the
run-up to Vicksburg Lincoln also saw
damage done to people that he did not
know intimately a reporter named Noah
Brooks
accompanied him to a visit to a
soldier's Hospital this was something
that Lincoln and his wife frequently did
and as Lincoln and Brooks were going
down the row of beds there was a
charitable lady ahead of them handing
out tracts and one young man looked at
the tract he was given laughed a bit and
tossed to the side when Lincoln and
Brooks came up to him Lincoln gently
reproved him saying that the lady had
good intentions it probably wasn't nice
to laugh at her tract and the man said
well she's given me a tract on the sin
of dancing and both my legs have been
shot off so now that has the shape of a
joke it does have the shape of a joke
but the joke was on Lincoln and on the
legless soldier of course so you
multiply these incidents by a hundred
and by a thousand and by 10,000 because
of course Lincoln is the
commander-in-chief he receives all
casualty reports all casualty figures go
straight to him and this is the toll
that this war is producing so Lincoln
turns to a fifth father God the Father
in 1862 he writes a note to himself it
was not not not for public circulation
but his Secretary's preserved it it's
often published as the meditation on
divine will and Lincoln tries to figure
out tries to explain what is happening
almost as if it were geometrical proof
and he begins by saying God rules
he says God cannot be for both sides at
the same time that would be a logical
contradiction but he may not be for
either side the war could not continue
without his will the war continues
therefore he must will that it does
continue and the culmination of these
thoughts comes in the second inaugural
when the war is almost over March of
1865 it's the most religious speech ever
given by a president of the United
States now read you two sentences if we
shall suppose that American slavery is
one of those offenses which in the
Providence of God must needs come but
which having continued through his
appointed time he now wills to remove
and that he gives to both North and
South this terrible war as the woe do to
those by whom the offense came shall we
discern therein any departure from those
divine attributes which the believers in
a living God always ascribed to him if
God wills that it continue until all the
wealth piled by the bond man's two
hundred and fifty years of unrequited
toil shall be sunk and until every drop
of blood drawn with the last shall be
paid by another drawn with the sword as
was said three thousand years ago so
still it must be said the judgments of
the Lord are true and righteous
altogether now you can see from this how
far Lincoln has traveled from Thomas
Paine Thomas Paine was revolted at the
notion of God requiring his son's
sacrifice as the atonement for sin but
now Lincoln is telling America that God
requires the deaths of thousands and
thousands of sons north and south for
sins of their fathers and their fathers
fathers for 250 years it's also striking
that in this speech and it's really the
only speech of the 1850s and 60s except
for the house divided speech the
founding fathers do not appear in the
Gettysburg Address the historical
subtraction was four score and seven
years ago that went back to 1776
but here the number is 250 years of
unrequited toil 250 from 1865 is 16 15
that's Jamestown
the first American colony the first
American colony to buy African slaves
the founding fathers have become a
dimensionless point in this history of
national slavery that's not the end of
the speech there's a last paragraph it's
one sentence with malice toward none
with charity for all with firmness in
the right as God gives us to see the
right let us strive on to finish the
work we are in to bind up the nation's
wounds to care for him who shall have
borne the battle and for his widow and
his orphan to do all which may achieve
and cherish a just and a lasting peace
among ourselves and with all nations now
what struck me when I came to write
about that is how many of those verbs
are two syllables verbs are verb phrases
strive on finish bind up care for do all
achieve cherish and it seemed to me that
it's like walking it's as simple as
walking it's as hard as walking on when
you've walked so far and you have so far
yet to go
a month later Lincoln was murdered and
we still walk on thanks very much